it reminded me of when I went to the
fight with louis c.k we went and saw
triple G fight in the garden my first
boxing match second row seats
thanks to Louis and Trump was there and
this video of chip trying to get Trump's
attention literally video of chip-chip
person trying to talk to the President
of the United States in the same room
like chip was in earshot oh if you eye I
don't know where the video I think I
tweeted it a while ago it's probably
almost the year was last December no
that's so funny that's all so yeah at
chip chip person maybe uh go to add chip
chip person I think but yeah I just I
forgot that existed until her chips
voice that's so great then you have an
interaction with somebody that could be
oh there it is oh wow again just no
inner he doesn't say
we like your job you get to help
you can hear going to going to be the
president so Donald is one row and four
seats over from chip chip person didn't
hear him that was allowed chip was
louder than you can hear at a background
it's a little hard to hear because of
the loud music that was playing yeah
but chip was obviously yelling hey
Donald hey Donald you're going to be the
president I want to be the vice
president hey Donald oh you had one
interaction with somebody who is going
to be the president the United States of
America and it was chip that came out
yep he's taking over your life I didn't
go over and say hello you didn't know no
because you couldn't go over and say
hello
cuz chip had already yelled at him he's
literally he's actually yeah he's three
or four seats over yeah and road ahead
of us yeah it's literally it's it's a
it's one yard it's three feet there's
three feet of distance between you two
yeah gonna be the president I want to be
the vice president yeah